this is something that we ask a lot on
the show and I think you'll be good to
ask you this one yeah it seems to be
that exponential technology is
exacerbating wealth and equality quite a
bit as in the rich are getting very very
very rich and are now able to use
genetic engineering and neural
prosthetics and space colonization and
cryptocurrency and all these different
sorts of means in order to exacerbate
their wealth and improve their wealth
versus the poor very very very slowly
increasing their wealth across the world
what do you think about a potential
class-based speciation do you have any
concerns about wealth and quality what
are they
it's happening you know we so technology
affects our lives in so many ways we
tend to ignore the positives first so
let me talk about the positives we have
never had a longer life expectancy in in
the modern history of humanity we've
never had you know better transportation
better quality a better health care
better you know quality of living in
general lots of things are so much
better and they're going to continue to
get better yes but we've also never had
so much bullying huh so we got maniacs
it's really it's really crazy and so I
when I was growing up I you know there
were two bullies in school that we had
to worry about right maybe I was one of
them I'm never gonna say that but you
know anyway today every every teenager
has to worry about a billion bullies I
mean there are all over the internet yes
tens of thousands right so so there is
an adverse impact to that now technology
interestingly is just the tool so you
can walk I think at eight kilometres an
hour if you get in a car you can get up
to 280 kilometers an hour technology is
just magnifying our abilities so it's
also magnifying our problems but it's
just the tool I can use this glass to
drink water or I can hit you on the head
where it is is it the problem of of the
glass it isn't the gloss the glass is
just a tool
right we've abused technology we've also
submitted to a world where we allow
technology players to do whatever they
want and we just submit and go like yes
master we're gonna use it as you're
offering it to us and and I love Apple
right but as long as we keep buying
fancier and fancier phones they're gonna
make fancier and fancier phones right
until we take a stand and we say hey by
the way guys next phone should reduce
the amount of time I bend my head and
look at it you need to make me more
productive you need to make me happier
otherwise I'm not buying it they're
gonna make that happen if we go to
Hollywood and say no more violent movies
they're gonna make comedies right we
don't exercise our rights to choose okay
put all of that together and then ask
yourself where our world is going our
world has not advanced that's the
problem so we have more toys for the
wrong why but believe it or not if you
truly look at our world today we as
humans hmm
we're not advancing at all we're
actually declining we're not progressing
in our own humanity right so the
technology is progressing for Humanity
in is declines the climbing so so the so
the reason why we have dating sites is
because we're unable to connect anymore
we're unable to walk out there and see a
wonderful person and walk to them and
say hi mmm right and and so the
calculator the scientific calculator is
helping you solve more math problems
because you're unable to calculate
yourself anymore right the dating site
is hopefully some you know complementing
the weakness that we were developing and
connecting the you know the social media
is trying to give us more virtual
friends because the value of friendship
of every one of them is less than the
true value of us right meeting each
other just hugging each other just
looking each other than other
in the eyes and the problem is becoming
massive and I I don't know how many of
you have seen my 1 billion happy video
the problem is we are at the cusp of
handing over everything we've learned to
machines yes right and and so the
reality is general intelligence AI is
real huh
yes III is more than real we are here in
the heart of it huh general intelligence
is 10 to 15 years away in 10 to 15 years
time those machines are going to be
smarter than we are
right when they are smarter than we are
we are now going to hand over solving
all of the problems of the world to the
smartest one of us which is not going to
be a you the challenge is this if they
solve those problems from the same value
system that we have developed in the
last 70 years we're screwed if you go to
them and say solve global warming and it
is about a selfish greedy competitive
position like we have developed over the
last 70 years they're going to say sure
you're the problem right if I get rid of
you
we're going to be all fine right and and
what we need to build instead are
machines that have the value system of
an Indian subcontinent child I actually
use that example quite often you know we
all have Indian subcontinent friends
here who are brilliant they come they
code they develop businesses they become
millionaires or billionaires and then
they go back to take care of their
parents what are their philosophy and
their ethics why that's a great so
understand ethics and values we tend to
believe that ethics our values are like
mysterious they're not if a woman grows
up in Saudi Arabia she tends to believe
that the right way to fit in is to dress
conservatively she grows up in Brazil
she realizes that the right way to fit
in is a g-string right that is one of
them right and the other is wrong no
it's just the general behavior of the
society just like an artificially
intelligent machine we take as many
samples of it as well as
we can and then we say look this kind of
behavior makes people like me that kind
of behavior makes people dislike me so
I'm gonna do that behavior right and
that's what the machines are learning
the problem is if machines look at one
Donald Trump tweet today they're not
gonna see any problem if they look at
the one Donald Trump tweet and the
30,000 hate replies below that's a
massive problem yes because to them they
will learn that that's the way we do we
resolve conflict where we treat each
other that's the way we treat each other
so general intelligence will be
developed to say when someone says
something I disagree with I should
thrash them insult them give them hate
speech and not even ask for what I want
just make them feel bad right great
we're being amazing parents here for our
artificially intelligent children mmm
right that needs to change we need to
all have seven and a half billion
conversation about being the parents to
the artificial general intelligence and
that's exactly what about 1 billion
happy is all about